Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today you are going to witness how an AI learned
to perform these amazing juggling
skills. And not only with the ball.
And I am very excited for this. Why is
that? Well, because I see that this paper
was co-authored by our friend, Sebastian
Starke, which means that an amazing paper
is almost guaranteed. He was behind this
work too, and many other amazing papers.
Now, creating a little AI that can learn these
kinds of skills seamlessly is immensely difficult.
Why? Well, the two hallmarks of a great animation
system is that the transitions between movements
are great and that no foot sliding happens.
And, as you see, this previous technique is
unfortunately not it. Yet, you see this kind of
animation in a lot of computer games, even today.
And, unfortunately, it gets even worse. Look!
The ball does not obey the laws of physics. So,
it seems that getting quality animations
for gaming is absolutely hopeless. So,
is that it? Well, don’t despair quite yet!
Now, previous techniques required a lot of
manual labor in creating these animations,
and weaving these animations together. However,
today, we see more and more AI-based systems that
can have a look at a big soup of movement data
that shows how humans move. Why is that? Well,
this is a learning based system, so it has a bit
of an understanding of what is happening. So,
what does that give us? Well, hopefully exactly
what we are looking for! It promises a smooth
transition from any move into any other move.
Well, after seeing these previous results, I don’t
have very high hopes, so I will believe it when I
see it. This is how a previous technique was able
to animate this character. Not great. And now,
hold on to your papers, and let’s see the new one!
Oh wow. Just look at that! These animations are
indeed fluid, and no matter how we combine these
movements together, the AI is able to weave
them together into one smooth and believable
motion. It makes up these beautiful transitions
on the spot without ever having seen them. Now,
this captured my imagination. So what do
experienced Fellow Scholars like us do here?
Of course, we make it harder. Much
harder. How? Well, for instance,
let’s add wind to the mixture, constantly
blowing the ball away from the player. Wow,
that is unbelievable. Not a problem
at all for this new AI. It can adjust
to new situations, which is a hallmark
of an intelligent algorithm. Love it.
But wait! So what is the extent of new
situations that it can generalize to?
Let’s see. Oh, I love that. Turning motions
are also possible. It had witnessed people
turning around in the training data, and it
had seen people juggle. That is not a surprise,
but what is surprising is that it was
able to put the two together seamlessly,
so it can juggle while turning. That is
absolutely amazing. Now these results
are already very impressive, but let’s be a
little cheeky. So, can we ask for even more?
Well, you know what? No one said that we are
only allowed to juggle a ball. Who said that
it has to be a ball? It could be a box.
And my goodness! Look! It still works.
And it also works with an American football.
Or even, yes, you are seeing correctly. It even
works with toilet paper. So, who is better,
the AI or Lionel Messi? Well, let’s see.
Look at that! Haha! Joke’s on you, little
AI! Team Humanity vs Team Robot - 1:0. But,
unfortunately it gets even worse. I am not
sure if I should be showing this to you, so,
are you prepared? Are you sure? I think
you are not prepared at all for this,
so if you continue the video, it’s on you.
You’ve been warned. Okay…go. Ouch. Whoo!
This reminds me of an earlier paper where they
wrote up a musculoskeletal simulation system,
and hamstrung it in a variety of different
ways. That is, these poor little folks got
injuries and they simulated how they
would move afterwards. But worry not,
after this, simulating surgery
and healing them was possible.
So, after perhaps a similar
surgery, when this new AI recovered,
it was also able to do three amazing
things that I really didn’t expect.
One, it can juggle the ball with its chest. Two,
oh yes, this. I love this because this showcases
the advantages of a physics-based system for the
ball movement. It can stop the ball with its foot.
Or, three, it can also kick the ball up
to varying heights. And to think that it
can do all this from just a soup
of motion capture data. That is,
recorded movement data from real humans.
That is incredible. And remember, it had
never seen these objects before. Wow. I cannot
wait to try the video games of the future where
we will be able to control these characters
using this paper. What a time to be alive!
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!